[Music]
on the citizens of Joe Mallya I asked
what kind of questions do y'all have for
us and today we have a special question
from Elizabeth she said what are the
scariest things that have ever happened
to you guys while traveling I got a lot
of [ __ ] snow I have a story as well
okay start please go
well let me tell you this isn't scary
like threatening my life but the first
time I ever want to hear it
first of all everyone to Canada I didn't
realize that the border was so strict
you know I'm saying I was like oh you
know whatever yeah this is my first time
getting booked for a show especially
going over for business yeah so it was
it was in Calgary and and the only thing
the promoter told it was okay just tell
them that you know you're you're you're
hanging out with your friend I was like
all right cool
got it cool straight so I'm at the
border like okay what are you here for
I'm like what's hanging on my friend and
he's like all right and how do you know
your friend was like oh [ __ ] immediately
I was like I didn't know it was gonna be
going into more question I'm a celebrity
I don't know who I panicked and I was
like I was like oh I've never actually
like met her
you just said your friends oh you've
never never met her okay
um okay I'm here to get [ __ ] well so
then they're like how you know this girl
I'm like oh we like we live in having a
relationship on Facebook and this is our
first time meeting in that and so
there's an older guy he's like oh like
he tapped a girl behind him the younger
one he's like do people do this she's a
fire people do all the time but what was
[ __ ] up is I think for whatever reason
he [ __ ] searches my name uh no man so
so then he's like okay which is just
have a seat I'm like okay cool I'm sit
down
what does a database like Instagram oh
yeah just Google and then so he like did
you repent man who knows but then he
goes got a lot of booty pictures then
and then he goes home Tim what are you
uh he's like no no he goes Timothy come
here and and that's when I should have
had a hint because you know my real name
is Tim not Timothy oh really yeah
legally just cuz you go youtube.com
slash Timothy I know it's as a nice ring
to it
so usually people do the shorter version
but you went the long way because it
sounded better with DeLaGhetto now that
we're going by tim chantarangsu it's
like yeah i'ma keep it if you want
personal for that day I call you Timothy
no whatever didn't who really called so
and then adds up then so then the girl
behind them she goes oh so he's a liar
then and he looks at as she looks up at
me I'm like [ __ ] what are they looking
at right so he calls me always like so
they so what are you gonna be doing here
tomorrow what are you gonna be doing I'm
like I'm just hanging all my friend
wherever she wants to take me I guess
he's like no where are you going to be
tomorrow night
yeah so I'm like I'm gonna be wherever
she wants to take me and then the chick
storms in and she's like she's like
you're making yourself look stupid right
now we know who you are like what
without without proper permit yeah if
you're working you need like a working
yeah you need a visa so then he's like
do the waiting room I'm like [ __ ] I'm
gonna get like dumb gorgeous Canadian
jail so so I'm leaving like an hour I
felt like and then finally got call he's
back he's like he's like Timothy come
back I'm like he's like he grabs my
passport he's like you didn't even need
a permit you know he's like it's not in
a club it's just out of blah blah blah
cuz it was I got a car show he's like
signing a club or bar you ain't even
your permit I was like he's like do you
know what you're doing [ __ ] I was like
yeah I'm gonna be performing this thing
okay he's like if you know a bit bigger
you've been doing like menus that's
crazy cuz the only time I've been to
Canada was for work it was to do a show
just for laughs but it was twice but
yeah I don't know how that works because
they did pay us but it was like through
Canada maybe they did all the paperwork
ahead of time that's crazy
I've heard horror stories that people
they you know they want to travel light
so they have like their their carry-on
luggage but it's all merch and instead
start opening that
confiscate that people's guitars duh
like wait you're coming here for fun but
you're bringing a guitar that gets taken
away yeah ever since then I never lied
the board I'm like yeah I'll come here
to perform at this but I I'm like I'm
doing this it's not at a club it's not
at a bar it's at this video P and I'm
like yeah I tell him everything so is
that why they like say like are you here
for like work or vacation yeah
because my my friend books guests out in
the UK and they had a whole tour lined
up and they almost couldn't get Jim Jin
and his team because one of the DJ's
didn't know that they didn't have the
permits so he said yeah I'm here to like
do these events and so they're like [ __ ]
because they didn't have the paperwork
yeah yeah they take this [ __ ] seriously
bro because it is technically like a job
so they're getting paid and they're
supposed to pay taxes or whatever yes
was it sort of lager we're not getting
paid through them there for vacation
there for travel it's different not like
an actual gig yeah
like especially let's say if it's like a
big YouTube event and you know like
there's just like this YouTube alright
dancers have it the worst - is just look
like answers right so if you show up at
the airport and there's 12 [ __ ]
Filipinos with zigzag circus Olay cast
come in look you coming in with body
suits and a [ __ ] whole hula hoop and
[ __ ] one's a clown you know they're like
some of them are luckily one time we're
going to the UK and it wasn't until we
were literally right at the like we're
gonna talk to the customs or where I was
like oh my god wait wait wait we don't
have we don't have any so we're on a
story but I'm sorting permits there's
four of us okay you and me we would just
go together and you guys met on a trip
last time here really okay cool oh cool
and we got there's like all right so how
do you guys know each other like are we
at school and we're never say to her
like yeah and then me and me and him
there's like all right you see if it's a
party like yes cool for us we would have
been fun you know Wow well coming back
from a Bali village trouble I had at the
border was coming back home from Bali
which was our honeymoon we were on set
know
I mean as a year before after the
Singapore trip with maker so we were on
separate planes because maker paid for
Steve's play and I paid for my own
flight and they were like why you where
like who are you traveling with them I
go I'm just waiting for my husband
they're like why isn't he with you so we
just got engaged so it's even more
confusing yeah they stopped me in
America is my point
yeah man it's a struggle doesn't it suck
when Authority ask you questions and
even though they're really basic
questions but I just said during that
weird situation like dad's like where's
your husband well he's over there why
isn't he with you and that just makes
you seem like you're [ __ ] normal stop
asking me that way well to the side and
I asked you additional questions well
besides that like before you board the
plane
I got randomly selected to be like asked
additional additional questions they're
like did you purchase anything here Mike
I bought a mug from one of those
souvenir shops they're like was it over
$10,000 like no no we like 1995 I don't
remember
I've got to randomly select like 5 times
in a row yeah same in Europe especial
yeah every time I was going to fly it
like they would pull me out like I would
have like the longest talk they believed
I was under 18 and then you know we like
1450 you don't have an ID yeah we want
to fly you diseased are you traveling
with your family or someone like my
brothers or something yeah a little
stubble god that's true you don't Angus
don't look your laundry we eat at this
age yeah yeah would you look when you're
in nineteen when I met you 19 or 18 18
you're 18 and you still look like this
yeah I thought you're older than me when
I met you yeah same yeah dude we would
go to Vegas this guy's 1819 and they're
carting me and not him only when I talk
about anyone do they they start carding
me like everywhere I think was just like
the confidence baby I think when I was
21 I still felt like it was wrong but
even to this day when I go I feel like
off like I'm gonna get [ __ ] up like
it's all gonna work but how much of a
blessing is it now and people ask for
your IDs though though I was dope
whenever I don't like it I love
when people wanted really when I wanted
drinks and they're like absolutely I'm
like thank you well the policy at a
restaurant is if they look under 35 you
card yeah just tie it cuz I'm over 35
under 35 because I feel like I got it I
just [ __ ] put my wallet away again
get all lazy and then you have you bring
your strap around zippers that's me
what's next time know if you travel with
the kid you actually have like special
benefits you get to go in with the first
class yeah yeah so I forgot where we're
going but it's supposed to be
technically under one cousin you got to
situate the kid and put the stroller
away but when I heard that I'm like oh
yeah you didn't while you passed him for
under one what was he - yeah we were
doing that advising up until he was like
eight or something you know how they say
like oh if you served like the military
something all too local a call duty that
they just sort of acts like they get up
in the Laotian oh yeah I'm a veteran uh
one of my boys we were he was super late
for this flight who's after playlist
right and I remember seeing his stories
the night because we're on the same
flight I seen his stories he's like out
party mad late I was like you know he's
gonna miss this flight and then I [ __ ]
I'm at my I'm at the terminal and then I
see him getting wheeled up and I'm like
I'm like bro
how did you get here he's like dude if I
went I knew I was gonna be late for the
[ __ ] flight so like my friend and my
crutches and like if you go to the
airport and they see that you have a
broken leg they will reel you past like
through security and all that so you
know you can skip the line I was like
what so he bypassed all that [ __ ]
he's mark yeah and then he was he didn't
have to go through like the long flight
people do that that's because it's lying
yeah you win by being a lazy drunk
actually my scariest moments much -
scariest moments traveling we're both
involving Steve being [ __ ] sick or
hurt while we were trying to fly home
so the scariest one was Costa Rica we
talked about that one before those two
years ago and we got stuck there because
he had kidney stones in this most remote
part of Costa Rica like on the peninsula
where you have to drive 45 minutes in a
bumpy ass car just to get to an airport
to drive to fly you to the other airport
to take you internationally yeah it was
[ __ ] scary and he got kidney stones
on the second day we were there the
whole trip yeah the whole trip we were
just stuck in the hotel room
[ __ ] off at first because he's got a
head of pain I was like it's nothing and
then he killed over he couldn't move
he's on the floor he's like just leave
me just go home without me everything's
closed on Sundays there's no doctors no
we don't speak Spanish so it was really
hard to get him a doctor from and he's
like eating the [ __ ] Street then I
went to go get cash because everything
was cash at this part of the island and
you had to go way across the other side
of town to get to an ATM machine because
I ran out of cash and then the ATM
machine ate my card and then I had to
get my passport that it was back at the
hotel and I'm like oh my god I'm gonna
die here and I had to take care of Steve
so that was really really [ __ ] scary
and just like navigating that oh my god
I learned a lot I always have cash know
some sort of some of the language you
know something how did you know that
Steve wasn't busting one of those
colorblind things oh he was crying he
was act like a big [ __ ] I was like
there's so much morphine pumped into him
and he was still like it's ten out of
ten and I'm like oh my god I have never
seen him ever how many days until he
passed the stones he didn't pass so he
we had to wait a month because it was
right around Christmas time took a
flight little stones in yes and then for
a month we couldn't get an appointment
to get it surgeon
so we had to go to the emergency room
two weeks after we got back home it was
all during Christmas time so
everything's like shut down and then it
was New Year's so like everything's shut
down again and so we in order to get an
appointment it was like we had a book it
like three weeks in advance and then we
went to the emergency room just so he
could get some morphine or some
painkillers or something they like did
some sort of like some not a cat scan
but something where they could see how
big the stone was and it was like a
millimeter or so almost a centimeter it
was ten millimeters so it was like a
centimeter civil war bullet yeah you're
gonna have to get that surgically
removed the first doctor we went to
wasn't covered by the health insurance
but the health insurance was covered the
hospital the second one the cot the
hospital wasn't covered but the doctor
was covered the [ __ ] health insurance
is crazy and you get charged for each
visit oh yeah nuts man and then you
finally got it surgically removed and
had a catheter and all kinds of [ __ ] I
feel like I'd rather have my kidney
still in surgically removing than
passing them through my people yeah
surgery yeah same because he had to have
a catheter for a week after the surgery
to pull that out like it's not like you
have sex at all that time oh no even
that was our biggest dry spell I was
like kind of pressure him I might come
on okay no it was pretty powerful I did
it passed through your nut dude my
urethra hurts just thinking about it
right and then the other time traveling
Steve got sick on the day we were
supposed to travel home he got crazy
sick with like the flu where he couldn't
even [ __ ] like lift his head and I
had a wheelchair him through the airport
through two international airports with
his luggage in my lucky mine was this
and everyone thought he was drunk too
much I'm like no really sick
[Music]
[Music]